welcome to the property investors
youtube channel which i believe to be
the richest rorish and realist property
investors resource on the whole of the
entire I'm pretty sure I know what this
is today's a good day this is hopefully
by YouTube plaque before I get super
emotional and give a speech I'm going to
open it just to make sure that it
definitely is what I think it is so so
very recently we hit a hundred thousand
subscribers this came to my house but I
just couldn't open it home without you
guys because I know that we've you know
this is like a team effort so I've
dreamed about this day for so long this
is basically a gift from YouTube when
you hit 100,000 subscribers you guys
ready it's quite heavy you've just done
something that very few youtube creators
accomplished
you had an astounding 100,000 people
subscribed to your channel yes we know
that numbers on YouTube can can get
really big but we hope that you don't
lose sight of the reality behind that
six digit milestone each and every
person who subscribes your channel has
been touched by what you created they
were inspired challenged or entertained
you achieve this milestone milestone
with hard work perseverance and probably
a healthy sense of humor to what you've
accomplished can't be taken away from
you and we'd like to recognize you in
all your hard work with this silver
creator award a small token of our
esteem and respect we know that you
don't do this rewards you do it because
you have a drive to create and share and
because you found an audience who cares
believe us when we say that we can't
wait to see what you do next a million
subscribers may seem a long way off
right now
but you're closer than you think and we
are rooting for you congratulations
Susan CEO at YouTube
amazing oh wow this looks great we got
all these little tokens and stuff
this is nice alright presentations on
you always fantastic Oh guys man thank
you you guys are amazing this is great
Wow I just don't know we should maybe
put it in the office since we put in the
studio I don't even know but um I do
member create my first video yeah I
remember I used to used to create videos
on my iPhone and and then where more
people wanted to see more videos took on
Nick full-time and then and then after
that we started taking on more more
videographers listen man I just want to
say I'm really pleased with this I know
he doesn't seem like a massive deal but
but to me and to us it's a massive
achievement because of what it signifies
and when it represents which is not just
one hundred thousand subscribers but a
hundred one hundred thousand people who
care about the content that we put out
and yeah we're not going to stop man
we're not going to stop we're going to
keep putting out content and I think as
well because we now got a hundred
thousand subscribers and we can justify
doing crazy things now like you know
spending crazy money on social
experiments doing more financial freedom
challenges putting out videos every
single day so I guess the I think I
really think the real hero in all of
this is not just the team it's certainly
not me but if you guys for watching and
following and commenting because without
you guys this this would you know
without the people that watch the videos
this wouldn't happen so massive respect
you guys who were subscribed really
humbled really grateful not going to
stop anytime soon gonna keep putting out
content to you guys because I believe
that everybody can be financially free
in property and I'm just gonna keep
singing that song and keep showing
people that it is possible I don't know
when when but certainly for the
foreseeable future
so does rock you guys rock as well thank
you so much
and yeah ma'am I've got nothing else to
say other than peace out thank you if
you're not subscribed subscribe below
keep binge watching the videos and I
hope to see you in person soon as well
if you see me in the street come and
shake my hand grab a picture if you see
me at an event then then you're you're a
rockstar as well so I'm gonna leave it
I'm gonna leave the link if you want to
meet me in person you want to meet the
team I'm gonna leave a link as well
below where you can come on down to some
of our events which are free on the
house we put out a lot of free stuff for
YouTube videos free books free courses
just because we really are on a mission
and that is to inspire and help people
to be successful in property and
remember your success he's my oxygen so
thanks so much I'll see you next time
[Music]